hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Freddy fazbear's
pizzeria simulator now we are in a whole
lot of trouble
oh I mean that's that's self-evident
interval of itself we we've made some
questionable decisions and we've got a
lot of animatronics that are ready to
crawl up our own a nooses and tear us
apart from the inside out which is a
weird sentence that I thought I'd never
have to say in my life but here we are
so I'm gonna evaluate what I'm gonna be
doing here and I'm gonna look very
closely at Lally's law it's apparently
I'm gonna be looking very closely at the
ins and outs of what we actually need
here but first I'm gonna go win myself
some tokens and what is a data archive
what's an egg Babli data archive I want
to find out but I spent a lot of money
on that thing better be good
[Music]
you're blocking the view that the duck
pond I can't all right then can I can i
play get a balloon we've got better and
bigger and greater prizes like this not
bad let's let's go with yes yes dead oh
[Music]
we're all whoa whoa okay there's a face
hey hey now there's a fake all right Wow
all right there's a face the background
face right there I saw it hello who you
is that me what the hell he said this
before I don't
that at all I'm so fast wait there's
something going on here
why why is why is there why is their
face in the background and why oh why is
why I'm just there's so many questions
of why then I have don't go out of
bounds cuz apparently that's terrible
for you okay I gotta get not there Oh
what was that that I just saw wait a
minute wait I oh hi what are you and why
are you there and what are you doing and
who do you think you are hey that's a
slug way to get to you how do you get to
you hey whoa Wow goober
oh no slug of Invista
oh oh that's handy that that is very
handy okay well I'm about to win I guess
down some lonely fruits I did it I got
an amazing I don't know what that means
what does that mean okay
good i'ma get oh good I'm gonna get foxy
okay I'm gonna get foxy cuz I like foxy
and you know how I don't like this pig
and I just I just don't see foxy there
hey foxy on the Left lefty on the right
let's do this bad boy I'm gonna die okay
we're gonna get into the thick of the
game and this time I know how to play
kind of a little bit but not entirely so
I'm gonna just do this to the best of my
ability and not die while also listening
out for the things in the dark that are
waiting for me okay I can't hear [ __ ]
[Music]
you can go away now
hey how's it going over there in the
other vent you can go away too
[Music]
okay any time now assume you went away
oh hey you didn't hear that annoyingly
loud advertisement did you then I
shouldn't have taken because advertising
ins are very bad for me from health
actually
[Music]
nope oh hey how's it going you remember
me the guy who wasn't making any noise
over here yeah yeah you can forget all
about me and how I don't exist
ah I hate this I hate this I hate this I
hate this go come it's just comes okay
we're all laughing at funny jokes over
here funny funny man over there that
ain't good ah is up I'm here in front of
me I don't know I don't know
I don't know but I'm alive amazing
let's make as much noise as possible
right in the now
okay okay okay okay go go go go go
okay alright everything seems fine I
don't know why glad I don't know which
way I don't know which way Oh No
I'm nowhere and everywhere that's how it
works in the show business I'm sober
okay well I'm boned I'm boned
I'm boned I'm boned I'm boned it's a
good thing I created this game it's a
good thing I'm really good at this game
hey I hear you crawling squeaks walking
over in the beds I'll have none of that
thank you
let's go loud push why not why not why
not cuz I'm ballsy yeah everybody shut
up for a second
I hear that come on hey how's it going
over there right I'm nothing I'm no one
no one
I'm no one to nobody
something tells me I hear screaming
happening in the hallways it's bad
probably
all right everything's fine everything's
100% hunky Dukey everything's a buzzes
everyone says move everything is upon so
nervous
everything Ponder's hundreds of
resemblance everything is black shirt
back off as a precautionary measure
clean those up and clean them good scrub
it up Bob scrub a dub I heard that on my
left and I'm gonna risk it I'm risking
it why am i risking it oh that am i
right too
[Music]
hood that I heard all of that you may
not recognize me at first oh sure that's
still me no I don't think so I don't
know who it is I don't know who and
where and what and why no stop going in
the fence I don't have time for this
it's gonna get real toasty up in there I
think it's fine why I just heard it
again but I think it's okay I have an
order in quick supply [ __ ] it I heard
you okay anyone that's no good okay
we're good we're good
yeah the utensils get two utensils don't
you tonsils you Tunde lose I just heard
that now you move you move there you go
that's it that boy Dadda boy oh yeah
that a boy beets gets that one really
wants really once in here
that was you sliding in or sliding out I
don't know which whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa hey whoa lefty lefty if that's you
lefty I ain't about that
okay all right or you can join in too
righty see fire both why both why both
why would we do both slide out noise I
think
does that slide back in
Oh for me oh man I was doing good I was
doing good man I only only had so much
left oh [ __ ] I was doing so good
Teddy sprinkles this day it's hard okay
so I gotta get the hard ones out of the
way first I think that's is guaranteed
because otherwise I'm just gonna be
boned forever that's a little early to
be a douche the whole time lolly printed
printed printed Honka Honka Honka Honka
so there's a noise for them going in
promise
going into the vent and coming like just
into the hallway outside event they're
different sounds but I think they all
relate much like sister location 20 mode
they all do kind of relate yeah see that
was just entering the hallway ooh what
what that was entering the vent there's
so many things to do this always goes
that wait right here
whoa both sides that's a new one I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead
dammit I'm gonna get this I got this I
got this I don't care how hard it is I
don't care I'm gonna do it maybe turning
the computer off isn't always the best
option but I think I think there's
something about having the computer on
to be able to check where they are
turning the computer off is a good thing
but also if I can just turn the fan off
because that creates most of the noise
which is what leads them to me
[Music]
okay that's how wacky Ward he's gonna
play it
why don't play by that [ __ ] not at all
I'm a man of patience I'm a patient man
one more just one more that's right you
walk away you walk away
you walk away you have no need to be
here walk away
walk away
walk away
[Music]
Hey Oh baby
holy [ __ ] hockey god this so stressful I
can't even explain how stressful it is
because like it's so tense and I have to
listen so quietly and you have to be
very very patient you can't rush or else
you're gonna be dead at least Lefty how
many new lawsuits do we have how many
new ones how many new ones oh boy look
at us yay oh wow I don't believe that
for a second
Oh more oh I guess it's just this is
just life down a mark down Wow look at
oh so I guess we've just gotta save up
until we get what we need it was
surprising that there's no big lore
stuff this time around but that's
because the big day is tomorrow in the
game it's Saturday and they told me that
I need to have everybody in one place
which is so fun and happy and definitely
not murderers in any way at all but
that's what we're gonna find out in the
next video so look forward to that thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you think down the comments
below and as always we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]